we do indeed Darius uh today a much more
peaceful game than yesterday how did you
recover after that crazy game and how
did you approach today's game tell us
your
story hi hi guys I'm glad to be here um
so yeah yesterday uh yesterday game was
totally insane um at some point I was of
course lost but um yeah I mean at some
point I was also winning uh after such a
roller coaster ride I was thinking to
take this game today so I mean pretty
much in solid manner especially I have a
bad memory of playing in round two
against Wesley two years ago in
singfield Cup Where I Was overly
ambitious and I got punished for that so
I wanted to take my uh take this day
more calmly and that's why I guess I
also chose this uh more quieter line I
wasn't expecting either five in the
opening um
so yeah I was P 98 um and after night
five um is also a move I had a game
against rajabov I think here uh but I
didn't really review this because Wes
was playing exclusively 98 and similar
positions so that's why I focus mostly
on that and I have some prepared some
ideas there based on some magnus's games
he played recently against I think van
Forest Darda also Guk in some online
tournaments so I had some inspiration
from these games he won all them I guess
so so I was uh hoping to get some some
going there of course there's nothing
special on this rugie one line but it is
it is what it is there's no one refuted
Berlin yet so absolutely and you also
wrote a couple of books on the ru Lopez
that definitely helped you in
yesterday's match did you uh feel that
influence coming from your books as well
and what about today's
game uh actually from both books I I
analyze these these lines um you know
for rookie one Merlin for white uh um
but yeah somehow I couldn't recall 9
five ideas and uh I what happens after
five and I was you know like I said most
mostly focus on 8 and yesterday's game
well in my books I cover Bishop C2 in
this smaller or ar Angel um but Bishop
Buffy also is a move that I heavily
studied too so um yeah it's one of the
most interesting and fighting opening uh
choices for black so I was thinking to
try it out yesterday and uh I had a good
position so I guess opening wise it was
a good choice uh later of course it was
very very complex and complicated but I
mean uh chess is a complicated game in
general so chess doesn't have to be easy
thank you very much darus go uh recover
get your energy back and we'll see you
tomorrow see you guys good luck indeed
uh just checking in on the Mishra versus
Andrew